Für die volle Konsolen-Experience
Habe ich jetzt mal auf 48 FPS runtergestellt
Vielleicht geht das jetzt besser
Stats... ähm...
Stats... ja ok
Mal gucken, ob es jetzt besser funktioniert
Es sind zwar nur 48 FPS, aber vielleicht geht das jetzt besser
Ja, ich glaube, es geht jetzt besser
Schaut mal, das hört selbst mal in der Vorschau an
Also ich glaube, jetzt ist besser
Das war aber noch nicht von Anfang an heute so, ne?
Das ist jetzt erst seit einer Stunde oder danach
Seit einer halben Stunde oder so gewiss
Hallo Game, ich möchte gerne spielen
Ich möchte gerne spielen
Ich glaube, das Game ist wieder abgestürzt
Ich habe keinen Bock mehr langsam
Das beste ist, das Game hat jetzt meine Maus gekrappt
Jetzt kann ich nichts mehr anklicken
Jetzt kann ich mal einen Task Manager öffnen
Ich habe echt keinen Bock mehr
Der PC-Port, was ist denn das?
Es kann doch nicht sein, dass es alle 20 Sekunden mal abkackt
Kannst du echt nicht sein